la fermeté mais mme thatcher elle
renvoie 51 votes pipoles de hong kong
vers le vietnam protestations
internationales
la pologne face à la réalité c'est
l'économie est en crise les salaires
vont être bloqués et les prix augmentent
les conservateurs marquent des points en
union soviétique les députés refusent
d'abolir le rôle dirigeant du parti
communiste de travail au noir en france
250 milliards de francs l'année dernière
autant que les revenus de l'agriculture
bonsoir la manière forte les
britanniques vis-à-vis des réfugiés ce
matin les autorités britanniques qui
jusqu'en 97 ont le pouvoir en kong ou
renvoyés dans leur pays
51 réfugiés vietnamiens ce matin à
l'aube
essentiellement des femmes et des
enfants ces réfugiés
ce sont ceux qui ont fui le vietnam
après la guerre ceux qui sont partis sur
des bateaux de fortune en laissant tout
derrière eux ce que l'on a appelé les
boat people
cette expulsion forcée a provoqué bien
sûr de nombreuses protestations
internationales et un tollé dans
l'opposition britannique
mais pour margaret thatcher c'est une
opération légitime
philippe harrouard le dossier
c'est l'image de la honte écrivent les
journaux britanniques inhumain
intolérable indéfendable prématurée
les critiques fusent devant les scènes
de la nuit dernière à hong kong
la police anti-émeute convoyant sans
leur consentement 51 boat people
vietnamiens de 26 enfants vers un avion
destination hanon la grande-bretagne
s'attendait à une réprobation générale
pour sa défense elle se réfère aux
nations unies qui en juin dernier ont
reconnu que les non réfugiés politiques
devraient être rapatriés cet après midi
au parlement madame thatcher a répété
que son gouvernement appliquer les
décisions de la communauté
internationale nous faisons ajoutent
elles ce que font tous les autres
gouvernements en renvoyant les immigrés
illégaux clandestins sur les 57 mille
boat people entassés dans les camps de
hong kong 40000 n'ont pas le statut de
réfugié politique
selon les critères de l'onu non
seulement hong kong est sursaturé d une
nouvelle vague de boat people et
prévisible en février
rien n'est fait pour les dissuader d'où
la décision de londres d'agir maintenant
cela peut également inciter certains
immigrés à partir volontairement avec un
pécule en poche londres explique que le
gouvernement de la noise lui a garanti
qu'aucune représailles ne seraient
exercées contre ceux qui reviennent à
faire regrettables mais nécessaires
estime le gouvernement britannique qui
veut impliquer la communauté
internationale si quelqu'un a une
meilleure idée
si quelqu'un veut prendre en charge ces
immigrés qui le disent et qu'il le fasse
embarras de tout le monde la solution à
long terme
c'est une aide économique au vietnam et
là encore le problème est international
mais en attendant que vont devenir ceux
qui reviennent dans un pays qu'ils ont
choisi de quitter à tout jamais ça c'est
la question immédiate
tout a commencé en 75 lorsqu'un régime
marxiste s'est installé au vietnam des
dizaines de vietnamiens ont fui en
bateau encore aujourd'hui plusieurs
dizaines de milliers s'en vont chaque
année mais comment les accueillir
le problème n'a jamais été résolue
bernard kouchner l'actuel secrétaire
d'état à l'action humanitaire a été l'un
des premiers à se battre rappel
tous les pays de la zone d'abord ont
refusé les boat people et maintenant
voilà que les pays de la zone avec des
complicités les renvoie chez eux
pratiquement de force ce qui me rend
très triste je ressemble maintenant des
bateaux comme île de lumière c'est
complètement exclu
c'est complètement exclu car il faudrait
que l'île de lumière maintenant prennent
les gens en mer et les ramènent
directement en france qu'on ne peut même
plus les déposer dans un des camps de la
région car de ce camp de la région ils
seront renvoyés directement au vietnam
donc les boat people ne doivent plus
partir il faut qu'ils comprennent qu'il
faut changer leur pays et d'ailleurs je
crois vraiment que l'ouverture des
autorités vietnamiennes et elle ils le
comprennent j'ai visité les vietnamiens
qui sont les boat people qui sont
revenus au pays
je crois que c'est la seule façon leur
faire comprendre qu'il faut changer et
l'économie et la politique de ce pays
avec les autorités de toute façon il
faut traiter humainement ces gens là il
faut peut être attendre un peu il faut
levier table avait promis ne pas
accepter communauté internationale et ce
qui reste de droits de l'homme de
l'ancien temps si j'ose dire ne peux pas
accepter qu'on les renvoie chez eux
contre leur gré c'est impossible en
pologne lech walesa réclament les pleins
pouvoirs pour le gouvernement actuel
gouvernement de solidarité c'est vrai
que la pologne se trouve confronté à la
réalité parle après les succès
politiques de l'équipe de solidarité
c'est maintenant le temps des épreuves
économique
c'est une potion amère qui va être
administrée à l'économie polonaise les
salaires bloqués les matières premières
vont grimper notamment le charbon l'une
des grandes ressources de la pologne
maryse mano et daniel lévy se sont
rendus dans une mine à katowice chez une
mine qui à partir du 1er janvier
prochain sera autogéré mais rien n'est
simple reportage
sainte-barbe priez pour nous chanter les
mineurs pour la fête de leur patronne
ils ont revêtu le costume d'apparat
plume noire pour les mineurs de fond une
blance pour les chefs d'equipe mais la
prière s'adresse aussi au premier
ministre mais l'objectif c'est lui qui a
dit il faut que les mines soient
rentables
une menace pour là aussi les i qui n'est
qu'une immense mine
trois cent mille familles vivent du
charbon à katowice en liminaire de père
en fils une élite ouvrière beaucoup
mieux payés que les autres polonais une
élite qui a tout à perdre à la
restructuration du charbon
ce puits va ouvrir la voie au 1er
janvier l'état lui laisse la liberté de
gestion
cela veut dire moins de subventions
hausse du prix du charbon et sans doute
réductions d'effectifs boleslav sait que
tout peut changer
depuis 15 ans il descend à la mine cinq
jours par semaine
sa femme travaille aussi au bureau de la
lean et pourtant ils adhèrent à la
nouvelle politique du gouvernement
il veut moins d'emplois administratifs
et un charbon payer à son juste prix le
prix du charbon est absurde
par exemple la tonne de charbon est payé
28 zlotys
c'est le même prix qu'un kilo de jambon
et puis il ya beaucoup trop de postes
inutiles dans l'administration on
discute souvent du chômage entre nous et
on se dit que c'est nécessaire pour
relancer l'économie
les slaves espère c'est que le chômage
ne le touchera pas directement
rien n'est moins sûr on estime à 20%
futurs emplois dans les mines
l'adoption des nouvelles règles de
compétitivité rend explosif
le retour à une économie de marché en
les conservateurs marquent des points en
union soviétique c'était cet après midi
la première journée de travaux du
congrès des députés est bien la majorité
des députés à refuser de débattre sur
l'opportunité de réduire le rôle
dirigeant du parti communiste gilles
rabin à moscou il plaisante mais il est
en réalité très inquiet il livre la
dernière d'une longue série de batailles
autour de l'ordre du jour du congrès des
députés du peuple
l'enjeu est de taille les députés du
congrès montrent ils oui ou non
débattre ans un des trois grands sujets
de polémique qui secoue lui resté tout
entière depuis presque un an
la propriété privée de la terre et des
moyens de production
l'indépendance politique des républiques
qui composent l'emplir la suppression en
fin de l'article 6 de la constitution
soviétique
l'article sur le rôle dirigeant du parti
communiste pendant plus de trois heures
mirail gambade sauf réussira à garder la
maîtrise des débats
interrompant les orateurs les plus
dérangeants d'alain variable une minute
camarades avec andreï sakharov il sera
même cassant au prix nobel de la paix
qui vient d'essuyer un échec
retentissant avec son mot d'ordre de
grève générale non civiles et paix et
qui lui remet à pâques et de télégrammes
favorable à la révision du rôle
dirigeant du parti communiste le numéro
un soviétique répond j'en ai trois
dossiers plein qui réclame le contraire
n'essayez pas de manipuler l'opinion
publique
malgré les ratés du vote électronique le
scrutin est sans appel on ne débattra au
congrès ni du rôle du parti ni de la
refonte de lempire ni même des lois sur
la propriété
ces trois dossiers brûlants sont donc
renvoyées à l'année prochaine
gorbatchev gagne du temps et il en a
besoin en effet à la toute première des
élections régionales qui doit être un
lieu dans chacune des quinze républiques
de l'urss
les élections de lettonie le front
populaire c'est-à-dire l'opposition
vient de remporter 90% des sièges le
parti communiste local n'a même pas
réussi à obtenir la totalité des 10 %
restants et comme tout change à l'est
les américains ne veulent pas être en
reste c'est pourquoi james baker le
secrétaire d'état américain est en
visite en allemagne
delhaize qu'en ce moment il s'est
entretenu aujourd'hui avec le premier
ministre de rda hans modrow à potsdam il
premier monsieur becker est le premier
chef de la diplomatie américaine
ascendant rda depuis la fondation de ce
pays il ya 48 des américains souhaitent
la stabilité du français issus de
réforme ce sont les termes de monsieur
baker le travail au noir en france à ne
pas confondre avec le travail clandestin
les travailleurs clandestins sont des
immigrés qui travaillent illégalement le
travail au noir c'est celui que vous
fait faire un plombier de la main à la
main ou à votre femme de ménage sans la
déclarer l'an dernier en france ce
travail aurait représenté 250 milliards
de francs selon l'insee c'est autant que
les revenus de l'agriculture en une
année jean pierre métivier bon vous le
payer en liquide
je ne vous fais pas de facture est comme
ça vous éditez la tva la phrase magique
qui rapporte 170 milliards de francs
voilà ce que chaque année les
entreprises ne déclare pas au fisc de
toute l'économie souterraine française
c'est de loin le gouffre le plus
important mais al sol
les nounous au noir les femmes de ménage
les leçons particulières les étudiants
baby sitter tout une domesticité
parallèle que l'insee chiffre à 13
milliards de francs versés de la main à
la main
ajoutons si les déménageurs à moitié
prix et surtout le bâtiment qui
concentre près du tiers du travail au
noir parfois avec des artisans mais
surtout avec des bricoleurs clandestins
et n'oublions pas le pourboire
le service non déclarés chez les
cafetiers les taxis les coiffeurs les
places de cinéma les dames pipi
au total 14 milliards et demi de francs
c'est le dernier poste de l'économie
souterraine économie ou noir c'est
quelque chose qui dégage autant de
revenus par exemple que l'agriculture
française
quand on parle travail au noir on pense
spontanément aux ateliers clandestins
on ne pense pas spontanément l'étudiant
qui garde les enfants à la femme de
ménage qui n'ont déclaré on ne pense pas
non plus spontanément à toute l'activité
qui n'est pas déclarée qui est
dissimulée par les entreprises ayant
pignon sur rue au total l'économie
parallèle aurait représenté selon
l'insee 250 milliards de francs en 1988
près de 4% du produit intérieur brut
pour consoler les moralistes le travail
au noir en italie reposante là bas près
de 20% de l'activité octobre dernier a
été marqué par une grève très dure chez
peugeot à mulhouse et à sochaux
au total elle aura duré sept semaines
cette semaine après françoise joly et
christian leroux sont retournés à
mulhouse
ils ont constaté qu'en trois mois 200
salariés ont quitté l'entreprise
pourquoi et bien voici le témoignage de
l'un de ses salariés un homme qui avait
12 ans d'ancienneté
depuis quinze jours le délai mon travail
ici à stan bar dans une entreprise
alsacienne qui a déjà recruté cinq
anciens ouvriers de chez peugeot où j'ai
retrouvé ici esprit et un contact humain
chose qu'il n'y avait pas chez peugeot
mon ancien employeur
aujourd'hui ce mécanicien gagne 1600
francs de plus par mois sans compter le
reste j'ai un cahier à la maison un
classeur qui m'a été fournie lors de mon
embauche avec toutes les possibilités de
prêts de financement d'assurance décès
de congé de tout ce que vous voulez
chose que on avait appelé jours mais
c'était un coureur du chef d'equipe
disant que la femme maintenant est au
courant de ce qui se passe dans
l'entreprise
ces trois derniers mois les 200 salariés
qui ont quitté peugeot n'ont pas pris
systématiquement la direction de la
suisse ou de l'allemagne là où pourtant
leur salaire est multiplié par 2,6 la
direction en eau ne réagit pas autres
mois qu'elle avait agi seul
le lion il perdre encore des points de
sa crinière
je reconnais qu'une chose c'est que chez
peugeot lui dispense très bon cours de
perfectionnement qui me servait
malheureusement chez mon nouvel employé
du chef jour comme les gens de chez
peugeot ont une excellente réputation de
compétence professionnelle et bien
effectivement nous suffisons
l'hémorragie on vient nous prendre des
gens qui sont très bien formés
donc ces départs selon vous ne vont pas
mettre en rapport avec un climat social
dans l'entreprise qui s'est détériorée
non le phénomène beaucoup plus d'origine
économique d'origine sociale mais
peut-être signe d'un malaise la
direction de peugeot mulhouse ne nous
autorisera pas cette fois ci à pénétrer
dans les ateliers par crainte dit elle
de provoquer une nouvelle effervescence
les syndicats eux parlent d'une
situation figée
avec la direction on a joué on n'a pas
de relation suffisante aujourd'hui qui
permettent de dire que l'avenir sera
beaucoup plus positif en termes
relationnel bref un mois et demi après
la fin de la grève
peugeot mulhouse vite encore en état de
crise comme si cette entreprise
n'arrivait pas à trouver une issue
définitive à sept semaines de conflit la
sphère le pen suite l'ensemble du monde
politique français en dehors du front
national approuve la levée de l'immunité
parlementaire de jean marie le pen
décidé hier au parlement européen de
strasbourg
écoutez ce qu'en dit est ce qu'en disait
tout à l'heure raymond barre interrogé à
rt je ne suis pas député européen ce que
je constate c'est que les propos de
monsieur le pen sont absolument
intolérable et puisque j'étais absent de
france j'ai l'occasion de le dire
publiquement ses propos à l'égard de
monsieur durafour qui fit ministre de
l'eco ministre de l'économie dans un
gouvernement dont j'ai le premier
ministre ses propos récents à l'égard de
monsieur stoléru qui fut secrétaire
d'état dans un gouvernement dont j'avais
premier ministre son dégoût version des
propos qui déshonorent ceux qui tiennent
de tels discours de tels propos
ceci dit je constate qu'une fois de plus
on donne à monsieur le pen
beaucoup de valeurs qu'on lui donne la
possibilité de s'exprimer et dans tous
les sens et d'apparaître comme une
victime
voilà voilà la situation
la brigade de sécurité des chemins de
fer a été officiellement installé ce
matin par pierre joxe il s'agit de
protéger les voyageurs et les employés
du réseau ferré de la banlieue
parisienne le ministre de l'intérieur a
aussi souligné que pendant la période
des fêtes de fin d'année la police
allait redoubler de surveillance dans
les gares par exemple et dans les grands
magasins jugement pardon justement
demain à paris ouverture d'un procès du
terrorisme
habib mare a mare est l'un des auteurs
de l'attentât 85 contre marx et spencer
boulevard haussmann à paris
il est jugé avec ses complices dominique
verdeilhan soit des issas oui c'est elle
qui en dénonçant son ex-compagnon abîme
ahmar a fait tomber ceux commis voyageur
du terrorisme c'est elle qui a tout
révélé aux policiers
j'ai dit que j'étais à paris c'était à
londres
c'est un magazine qui l'a laissée
l'attentât de l'enfer attentats de de
paris est malsain ça avec mon public je
leur demande d'avoir la brume que
j'avais la mi temps j'ai pris des notes
arrivé en décembre 80 de tunisie mama
recherche du travail à toulon ils
fréquentent ce bar c'est là qu'il va
être contactés par un dénommé kamel qui
lui propose un voyage à ankara kamel lui
révèle qu'il travaille pour le groupe du
15 mai à bagdad
mama rencontre le chef de cette
organisation terroriste abou ibrahim
durant trois mois mammare apprend à
manier les explosifs objectifs dictés
par un bruit brahim frappé les sociétés
aux mains des juifs
en décembre 83 pour 3000 $ mamar posent
une bombe au magasin marks and spencer
de londres il y aura deux blessés ou
2,84 nouvel attentat cette fois paris
contre l'avant lui me six mois plus tard
mama reçoit l'ordre d' abou ibrahim de
frapper fort
la charge qu'on lui remet et trois fois
plus puissante c'est l'attentât contre
mme arcand spencer à paris qui fait un
mort et 19 blessés
ma mort a fait déjà mais ne seront pas
en conformité avec les ordres de marc lt
reviennent c'est à dire qu'il est un
personnage à jj sa référence or c'est
qu'il va chaque fois et c'est lui le
plus possible les conséquences de ces
aveux en mai 86 ma mère est en prison à
nancy mais pour violation de domicile
souad qui se s'est trompée par son amant
se met à table à son tour
maâmar passe aux aveux ainsi est
identifié l'auteur de ces attentats qui
n'ont jamais été revendiqués
souad et habib se retrouveront pour
trois jours devant la cour d'assises
abou ibrahim l'instigateur de ces
attentats est lui toujours recherchés
abou ibrahim à qui l'on attribue la
confection de la bombe qui a frappé le
dc10 en septembre dernier et sur ce même
sujet le terrorisme c'est
l'effervescence dans ce moment au palais
de justice à paris après la mutation
d'un magistrat de lantier terrorisme
vers d'autres fonctions alors se donne
ton réellement les moyens de juger les
terroristes c'est tout le problème de la
14e section du parquet hervé brusini ils
sont tous spécialistes de
l'antiterrorisme
mais bientôt il ne restera plus grand
monde autour de cette table un à un les
magistrats de cette 14e section du
parquet s'en vont mise en place le 15
octobre 86 sous le gouvernement chirac
elle a d'abord vu partir son chef alain
marsaud l'homme n'a jamais caché ses
relations privilégiées avec ancien
ministre de l'intérieur charles pasqua
aujourd'hui alain marsaud est détaché au
sénat à présent c'est son successeur
laurence le vert qui doit aussi quitter
son poste malgré moi dit elle et tous
ses collègues d'affirmer que sa future
promotion ne serait qu'une façon de
l'écarter et l'on évoque de vieux
règlement de compte politique
en fait ces magistrats étaient en
désaccord avec les récentes mesures de
libération des détenus corses basse
guadeloupéen péripéties rétorque le
ministère la justice les hommes changent
mais la structure demeure une permet à
quiconque et je dis bien à quiconque de
dire de prétendre que parce qu'une
personne 120 il n'y aura pas de lutte
efficace contre le terrorisme la lutte
contre le terrorisme dépendent d'un
procureur de la république de ses
substituts premier substitut de son
procureur adjoint il y à toute une
équipe qui travaille elle dépend aussi
de moi et personne mais personne n'a le
droit de dire que cette lune n'est pas
menée hier aujourd'hui et ne sera menée
de mains avec la même détermination la
même volonté les mêmes moyens pour
l'heure les trois quarts des effectifs
du parquet spécialisés dans
l'antiterrorisme vont donc devoir
changer
or la formation sur de pareils dossier
est longue et au moment où une menace
terroriste semble se préciser
de nombreux magistrats jugent ces
départs inopportun
ayant maintenant d'autres informations
de ce mardi beaucoup d'informations
économiques vais aller le voir et on
commence d'abord par le chili louis
carzou fin de campagne électorale
mouvementée au chili plus de 20 blessées
hier soir à l'issue du dernier meeting
dans la capitale
parmi les trois candidats en lice pour
l'élection présidentielle
c'est patricio aylwin de la concertation
pour la démocratie
une coalition de dix sept partis qui
arrive en tête des sondages
les élections générales chilienne de
jeudi prochain des unions notamment le
premier président civil depuis 16 ans
drame à uckange près de thionville
quatre adolescents péri carbonisé dans
une carte de 3 mètres carrés les corps
des deux jeunes gens et de jeunes filles
ont été retrouvés près de la porte du
local elle-même détruites par le feu
seule l'analyse médicale devrait
permettre d'expliquer les causes du
drame
levée totale du contrôle des changes à
partir du 1er janvier 1990 déjà effectif
pour les entreprises depuis l'été
dernier la fin du contrôle pour les
particuliers interviendra avec six mois
d'avancé sur le calendrier initial
attention cette liberté des mouvements
des capitaux sera accompagné de
contrôles fiscaux plus strictes
le dollar à 5 francs 80 18 10 son plus
bas niveau depuis un an selon les
cambistes c'est la vigueur du 2e marque
à 3 francs 41 95 qui a entraîné la
baisse de la devise américaine
une force qui risque de semer le trouble
au sein du système monétaire européen
tous ces remous monétaire ont rendu la
bourse de paris très irrégulière ou la
séance s'est achevée sur une hausse
insignifiante de 0 05 % des agents
restent prudents devant l'évolution des
marchés des changes aujourd'hui 96 % des
français possèdent le téléphone chez eux
autant dire que tout le monde s'en sert
quotidiennement or le téléphone n'existe
vous le rappelle que depuis 100 ans
sentant juste même puisqu'on fête son
anniversaire lorsque le premier coup de
fil fut donné en france il y as entend
donc personne ne croyez vraiment à cette
invention
depuis c'est la planète toute entière
qui s'est équipée dernière invention à
la disposition de tout un chacun
le téléphone portable patrice pelé le
téléphone avec vous partout
la dernière évolution dans ce domaine
mais attention les prix sont encore
chers compter quinze mille francs et
surtout ajouter 3 francs par
communication et par minute
pour le moment seuls 160 villes français
possèdent un téléphone portatif ou de
voitures inventé aux états unis le
téléphone à ses débuts et méprisés et
puis par la suite
lentement il va conquérir le monde par
le câble pour commencer et grâce au
satellite
ensuite il va devenir l'ami le confident
de millions d'habitants sur la planète
on dit tout le téléphone ou presque tout
on l'appelle aussi parfois leur secours
votre aventure oui elle bull la
champigny c'est un accident
pourquoi et un découpage a juste
traversé qui ont roulé par une voiture
par une voiture la personne qui nous
appellent a besoin de nous donc il faut
que ça soit très rapide et nous avons vu
des moyens modernes téléphonique pour
que l'on puisse avoir son adresse très
rapidement on ne reste pas longtemps
avec la personne on n'a pas le temps de
discuter il faut que tout de suite on
envoie les moyens donc ça dure à peu
près 30 secondes
combien de vies le téléphone at il sauvé
aucune statistique ne l'a jamais montré
une belle revanche pour cette invention
qui à sa naissance n'était utilisé que
par certains qui a fait beaucoup sous
les hommages et transfert des cendres au
panthéon tout à l'heure à paris vous
avez pu le suivre sur antenne 2 en
direct juste avant le journal l' hommage
était rendu à trois hommes de la
révolution condorcet l'abbé grégoire et
mange un philosophe un religieux est un
mathématicien
le ministre de la culture et du
bicentenaire jacques lang leur a rendu
hommage
la cérémonie avait lieu en présence du
président mythique cinéma family
business c'est un titre anglais mais que
tout le monde peut comprendre enfin
j'espère le travail en famille et quel
travail
il s'agit de cambrioler les banques sous
les cagoules sean connery dustin hoffman
et le petit jeune matthew broderick
ils sont liés par les liens du sang ils
vont bientôt le faire couler mais tout
cela est très très drôle c'est signé
sidney lumet pts c'est une comédie
américaine nicole cornu langlois
trois gangsters ne vis plus tôt nul pour
un casse en famille
non
sean connery le grand-père canaille
pointe de la cambriole dustin hoffman le
père truand repenti reconverti dans la
boucherie mathieu baudry le petit fils
étudiant surdoué auteurs du projet trois
acteurs aux fortes personnalités et
pourtant un tournage presque aussi
désopilant que le film ça a été je dois
le dire extraordinairement façon
spontanée créatif marrant un peu comme
des répétitions au théâtre ils avaient
leurs textes mais je n'avais
pratiquement rien à dire
tout se déroulait les mouvements les
répliques on pouvait sans problème
passer la scène dans son intégralité y
compris les bagarres et les
affrontements chef croit tous les plans
ont été extraits à la fin du film
d'action parfaitement réglée film
comique rebondissements en continuelle
wesh
film attachant sur les conflits entre
générations
lui attend comme la plupart des garçons
il est en rébellion contre ce que son
père veut pour lui c'est pourtant ce
père vito n'est pas un mauvais père
véloce fondamentalement vito est plutôt
quelqu'un qui peut s'exprimer
physiquement il est touché si ces
sentiments sont atteints s'il est en
colère
j'avoue que je n'ai pas joué un tel rôle
depuis longtemps qu'un savant dosage de
rire et d'émotion
il y avait un tiercé aujourd'hui c'est à
vincennes alors nous allons voir les
résultats de ce tiercé 16,8 13,7 fès
13,8
les rapports je vous les laisse lire
c'était aussi un quinté plus je pense
que nous avons aussi les résultats alors
il ya deux combinaisons bien sûr il faut
ajouter la ce et le 11 avec des rapports
très long et très compliqué que je
voulais finir aussi la météo s'est tout
de suite avec laurent cabrol ce soir
henri sannier vous donne rendez vous
pour la dernière édition du journal à
23h30
bonne soirée à demain 20 heures